if not for her I don't know where most
of us would be today Decades of past
co-hosts of the view returned home to
honor the show's matriarch after she
passed away Friday at the age of 93. I
owe her everything I would not have this
career if she did not choose me she's
the goat she didn't just pave the way
the woman built the entire transit
system three two Debbie mattenopoulos
was fresh out of college when Barbara
hired her for the View's debut season in
1997. we have a 22 year old that's
Deputy 18 years later in 2015. Debbie
sat down with her Mentor for et in what
would be our final interview with the
legend the student interviewing the
teacher this is going to be tough do you
think I would give up the opportunity to
see you in spite of the fact that you
were a disaster I had to be here for
this she was so tough on me and she said
um
I just want you to know baby I knew I
was always right I was always right
about you
and I don't want to cry because she
would be so mad if I was crying right
now
sorry Barbara former co-host Sherry
Shepard also returned to the view she
told us Barbara's on and off-screen
personality couldn't have been more
different we would go out to dinner we
talked about sex non-stop she gave me
marriage advice that was like Barbara
she had a wonderful wicked sense of
humor Barbara stepped away from the view
in 2014 her last public appearance was
in 2016 at the premiere for the father
since then she chose to live a very
private life ET has learned she suffered
from short-term memory loss in her final
years the view was the first and the
fact that she was Fearless she was
undeterred and that's what I learned
from Barbara be curious be Fearless
don't take no for an answer
[Music]